we have an impactful story right here
in new york city people reports a woman
named maddie park
had the idea to raise money to pay for
safety cab rides for asian elders
it's such an incredible story and here
to tell us
is maddie herself welcome maddie
nettie i'm fine
thank you for having me you started at
cafe maddie cab on instagram
and you put 2 dollars of your own money
and within days you raised over
a hundred thousand dollars wow
maddie and i would love for you to share
how it all works
it only got started last friday because
last wednesday i was taking the train to
work
and i realized because of all the asian
hate crimes that i've been seeing
on headlines on instagram and all my
social media posts
i i became really scared in the train i
was terrified that someone might start
attacking me or harassing me so i
decided you know what
i only go into the office once a week so
i'll start taking the cab to work and
back and i noticed um
it's fortunate that i'm able to afford
these cab rides but i've been a student
here in new york city for almost 10
years
and that means i was broke in new york
city for 10 years so i just thought
about all the vulnerable asian people
out there
who are not able to take cows because
they simply can't afford it
and i just wanted to help some of my
followers who would see this
so that i can reimburse their cab rides
from my own funds
so this is just an initiative that
started with my own two thousand dollars
and i think uh people had the same
mindset or the same heart to keep the
asian community safe
in new york city and they started
donating and flooding with donations
you've inspired so many people and i
know you've also posted a guide showing
how to help asian elders who may not be
so tech savvy
exactly we are targeting the vulnerable
asian community the asian
woman in new york city the asian members
of the lgbtq community and the asian
elderly
who are especially been a target of
attack in new york city
for asian hate crimes so how you can
help the elderly
is obviously because they don't have
access to my instagram or the google
form that i have
in my instagram bio you can give rides
for
your parents or your grandparents who
need a ride to their medical
appointments or other essential rides
or if you see some elderly in the street
and you feel like
they are at risk you can approach them
make them feel comfortable
and explain that you can offer them a
ride home if they feel comfortable
and then you can submit a form on behalf
of them too
and now you're helping expand this to
other cities right how are you doing
that
i'm extending the invitation on
instagram and seeing if
anybody else in their own city want to
start the same initiative
and then starting an email chain so i
connect them with other leaders
or some other people who want to start
it in their same city we here at the
show want to add five thousand dollars
to your effort
no way yes thank you so so much
this means so much and i already
appreciate
the coverage that you are providing us
so that more people can access the
services
and thank you so much for the donation
as well
thank you maddie park for everything
that you're doing
and let's see what else is possible we
believe in what you're doing so much